[MUSIC]
Jobs at mills like this helped
shape the American dream and
created the modern American middle class.
And in their heyday, Pittsburgh steel and
Pittsburgh steel workers
were the envy of the world.
Today's groundbreaking is a sign that
a new heyday is coming for Pittsburgh and
for America.
One that will transform and
revive the American economy in
every corner of our great nation.
By bringing together large
scale academic research and
industrial development under one roof,
Mill 19 will become a true differentiator
for Pittsburgh and for the region.
When complete,
it will be the first manufacturing
hub of its kind in the nation,
in the world for that matter.
Researchers and practitioners at ARM and
MFI are quietly reshaping what goes
on inside factories and warehouses.
The technologies that
emerge from this building
will have the power to make things in
a whole new way, to trigger a significant
resurgence of major economic
sector in the United States, and
to assert our global leadership
in advanced manufacturing.
>> I believe that robotics is key to the
US competitiveness in manufacturing and
one of the major factors in the economic
prosperity of the United States.
>> Through cooperation and
coordination of our industry partners and
Carnegie Mellon, which is truly one
of Pennsylvania's greatest assets and
a global pillar of research and
development.
Our investment will help transform
an entire sector of the economy.
We are here today because government,
federal, state and
local recognize the potential
of this site of the region and
of these partners to usher in a game
changing manufacturing renaissance.
>> This site is envisioned as
a place where people will thrive,
ideals will be forged.
And this entire ecological condition of
the site will be regenerated over time.
>> I would like to acknowledge
Pittsburgh's foundations.
Especially Richard King Mellon Foundation,
the Heinz Endowments,
and the Claude Worthington
Benedum Foundation.
They had a vision and
a determination to pursue it for
more than 15 years in
the face of many challenges.
Carnegie Mellon University
owes an additional debt of
gratitude to the RK Mellon Foundation.
RK Mellon's gift to the university,
helped catalyze ARM, helped launch our
manufacturing futures initiative, and
helps support our participation
in this facility.
>> Today we celebrate not only the future
of manufacturing, we celebrate
the rebirth of a great community,
the historic community of Hazelwood.
And we understand that what
will happen in this building,
just like it happened 100 years ago,
will forever change this world.
[MUSIC]